[Música]
sin un acuerdo claro las negociaciones
para el documento final de la con 27
celebrada en Egipto se extenderán Hasta
mañana sábado el tema más controversial
es la ayuda de los países de
desarrollados a los más pobres para así
poder paliar las consecuencias del
calentamiento global saludamos a José
Luis García el experto en el clima José
Luis gracias por estar con nosotros en
directo América de Francia 24 está
mañana de viernes qué ha pasado entonces
en esta cumbre de la cop 27 en Egipto
que podemos conclusiones sacar digamos
en estas dos semanas de debates
pues lo que estamos viendo Es por un
lado que hay una enorme dificultad para
llegar a acuerdos porque los los lobby
de los combustibles fósiles la
corporaciones los combustibles fósiles
que están infiltradas en muchas de las
delegaciones de países están vetando que
se pueda acordar algo tan básico como
que hay que ir reduciendo el consumo de
todos los combustibles fósiles que son
la principal causa de cambio climático
luego eso es una parte importante del
problema otra es que la necesidad de que
hacer frente a las pérdidas y daños
causados por el cambio climático que
tendrían que afrontar lo costear los
países
más enriquecidos con más poder económico
para sufragar los costes de quienes no
tienen la capacidad de hacerlo pues se
están resistiéndose y no está no acaban
de de dar los pasos necesarios para
poner un fondo que coste esas pérdidas y
daños de los que tienen responsabilidad
los que pausado las emisiones pero que
sufren quienes menos emisiones han
causado y sin embargo pues
sobre ellos se trata de las
consecuencias de cambio climático José
Luis realmente han sido vinculantes las
decisiones que se han tomado en estas
acumbres del clima digamos desde los
acuerdos de París hasta la pasada en
Escocia y Y a esta que podemos
digamos ver no de estos avances es que
han tenido los países en materia de esta
transición energética
Bueno lo que se acuerda en el marco de
Naciones Unidas no es tanto la capacidad
vinculante directa que tenga sino el
efecto que supone en cuanto a que luego
los países lo trasladan a su normativa
por ejemplo la Unión Europea lo traslada
a su normativa que sigue obligatorio y
cumplimiento no Y así tiene que hacerlo
cada uno de los países pero estamos en
el marco de Naciones Unidas donde lo que
se llega esa consensor por donde tienen
que ir las
el acuerdo es decir si unos países se
acuerdan de una cosa pero luego no lo
cumplen Pues el acuerdo se hace
imposible porque no va a haber no va a
ser posible llegar a nuevos acuerdos
Y qué va a pasar con estas ayudas que
sobre todo el presidente de Brasil en su
intervención en acop 27 dijo que él iba
a estar ahí para reclamar y digamos
hacer esta exigencia y que estas ayudas
de los países más ricos realmente
lleguen a estos países en vías de
desarrollo esto digamos que puede ser
así Cuánto dinero además estamos
hablando y por qué como lo denunciaba el
presidente de Brasil el presidente
electo de Brasil Lula da Silva estas
ayudas no han llegado realmente a estos
países
no han llegado y porque Sencillamente no
ha habido la voluntad política el
compromiso por parte de quienes tenía
que aportar los fondos Es decir los
países desarrollados es muy importante
que entendamos Que Aquí no se trata de
hacer una un acto de generosidad se
trata de cumplir con la responsabilidad
de quienes se han enriquecido causando
un problema y tienen que compensar a las
víctimas de ese problema Entonces hasta
ahora se están resistiendo a la creación
de este fondo que compense las pérdidas
que posteen las pérdidas y los daños que
causa el cambio climático y además es
que es no está cuantificado de cuánto
dinero puede ser porque desgraciadamente
cuanto menos se se avance en frenar el
cambio climático mayor Serán las
consecuencias y por tanto los daños y
las pérdidas que habrá que cubrir Pero
además de esto había ya el compromiso
desde París de aportar 100 mil millones
de dólares al año por parte de los
países desarrollados solamente para
costear la adaptación al cambio
climático hacia aquella parte del cambio
climático que ya no se puede evitar por
parte de los países
con menos de su global con menos
capacidad económica esto tampoco se está
cumpliendo es decir ese compromiso que
ya se dio no se está cumpliendo y ahora
se evalúa que el dinero necesario
Debería ser del orden del triple a aquel
que se comprometió Bueno vamos a
averiguar Entonces es que se concluye
mañana no con esta declaración final que
se espera de esta cop 27 José Luis
gracias por estar con nosotros esta
mañana de viernes en directo América de
Francia 24 un abrazo
gracias a